my fondest memory as a kid because like
because australia every [ __ ] house
has like a pool in it because otherwise
you can't survive the first luxury
yeah you can't survive the summer
otherwise but um my fondest memory and i
don't know if this is like a collective
like memory for everyone like every kid
who like swam in a pool but did you used
to do this thing where you would
go under the water and then you would
pretend to like walk
yeah because i feel like you're in like
on the moon
of course that's the only memory i have
of being in a pool
even though i went to swimming school
for like seven years
to like learn how to like do all these
like different swimming things and like
all these fun activities and whatnot the
only thing i remember is like
yeah i'm on the moon
[Laughter]
what intelligent thoughts is joe yeah
the whole time you were talking about
like the pool that's in my head was just
that was just replaying over and over
again i'm like i want to go swim in a
pool again
it's sad because it's so [ __ ] hard to
like find a place to swim
no pools they hate swimming for some
reason unless you know you [ __ ]
pay 150 bucks a month to go to a gym
that also just happens to have a pool in
it i'd pay to go to a
gym with a pool in it [ __ ] i just want
to go to like a pool i have i
haven't seen a pool anywhere yeah
honestly it's always weird to think they
just don't like pools
yes well i mean i don't know how
statistically correct this is but
there's
a lot of even adults in japan that would
just never learn
to swim yeah i mean like if it wasn't
part of everything if it wasn't part of
my curriculum i probably would not have
learned how to swim
like i don't know where i would have
gotten the motivation to be like okay
i'm going to go out
and figure out how i'm going to [ __ ]
there's yeah let's play through waters
everywhere in the uk yeah because then
it's in the public
yeah yeah exactly you pay like two
pounds and yes
because in australia it's almost like
second nature to be like oh your kid is
like three to five years old well then
we're gonna take you to swimming school
no question as someone who's a lifeguard
has there any like was it
pretty common for like you to find
pieces of [ __ ]
in your pool just like yeah it happened
like so from
like a year it was like code brown so
it's like
that's what it was you'd have to you'd
have to empty everyone has to get out
you have to close the pool
because you have to really you have to
re-sanitize it because it's like it's
like yeah
obviously yeah yeah because like
obviously there's tons of piss in there
but you can't see it but
you see a giant mars bar floating in
there you gotta you gotta fish you gotta
fish it out and then you gotta kick
everyone out
same if like someone throws up i think
more people threw up than
throwing up in a pool oh i guess from
drinking all the pool water maybe people
some kids are stupid they they would
like
some of them would drink the pool water
yeah yeah some of them would just eat a
lot and they'd like jump around and then
swim a bunch get really exhausted and
then they would
yeah yeah how long would it take to
[ __ ] sanitize the pool i don't know
we had like a roomba
that did it there's like a roomba that
went around like the bottom and there's
a bike oh yeah like the
little and it yeah clean it
but the water is like never like emptied
yeah it's um
it's just like it's just salted right
yeah yeah yeah and they there's gonna do
a chlorine test every
like two hours yeah make sure the
chlorine levels are okay but
i i never did that i wasn't allowed to
they were like we don't trust you with
the clawing
chlorine connor get out of it no i mean
i was i was never like a manager there
so i just i was just like there yeah
just because i i i remember still having
like [ __ ] vivid memories as
when i was like learning how to swim
just like finding a [ __ ]
in in like the swimming pool right it
happened like twice i think
yeah because like it would it would
never float it was
it would always be at the bottom yeah
and like as a kid i was just like
you because i was always been
short-sighted i was always short-sighted
right right
in my entire life and i didn't know this
until i was like maybe 10 years old that
i was short-sighted
oh my god actually i remember
i remember i remember as a kid right i
would be looking sitting really close to
the tv
because like like when playing games or
whatever my mom just like stopped
sitting so close to the tv
and i was like but i can't see it and my
mom's just like look harder
i was just born with bad eyesight you
know unfortunately so as a kid
i didn't have glasses at the time so i
would be swimming in the pool and i
would see this like little
i remember seeing this like little black
[ __ ] thing like
in the corner of this pool right and you
do and it was it was it was [ __ ]
blurry as [ __ ] right so i'm just like
what the [ __ ] is this black thing no
in this in the corner i've never seen it
and so like out of you know they say
curiosity killed the cats
um so uh me being the curious little you
know
[ __ ] six year old i was or whatever
like i swim
closer and closer to it right
i'm looking back i can hear the [ __ ]
jaws music just playing in the
background i'm like
i'm done and so like i'm it's i start
swimming closer and closer to it and it
starts like
slowly slowly slowly slowly coming into
focus right and it starts like okay so
it becomes this blurry mess and it
becomes this
cylinder shaped thing and i'm just like
what the [ __ ] is a cylinder shaped thing
doing
in the swimming pool right right and so
i get closer and i get closer and then
i'm literally like
so the shit's there right and and so i
literally was just like
and then i like when it when it felt
like cause cause like when it fully came
into focus
obviously when i'm this obviously when
i'm this close i can see the entire
[ __ ] detail you're like two inches
away from a piece of [ __ ] yeah yeah
like you know you can see the [ __ ]
texture of the [ __ ] right now
like that's how detail there was in my
mind i let out the biggest
underwater scream i had of my [ __ ]
life
it was literally like a [ __ ] horror
movie when i'm just like
you know you know what the the
that's such a good story such a great
the weirdest time
that there was a [ __ ] in the pool and
this happened only twice while i was
there
and i was just completely confused how
there was a [ __ ] in the pool
yeah and we i still to this day cannot
figure out what happened
so i'd love some scientists in the chat
to explain what the [ __ ] happened yeah
so they would do this thing at my pool
where they would have like
uh like how to learn how to kayak so
they would let like
uh like six like in the pool yeah they
would let people
put six kayaks in the pool and just let
people kayak around it
and i don't know how this happened but
after the kayak has left
there was a [ __ ] in the pool now they're
in kayaks
how do they get in the pool did some of
them just window out like put that butt
out just for a second just like
squeeze it out how does that happen how
does this [ __ ] in the pool after kayaks
does anyone have an idea of how this
happened because we were all completely
confused and
luckily it was the end of the day but we
were just like how is this [ __ ] in the
pool you're like looking back on like
the security footage cameras like
we gotta find the exact moment where the
boot came out we wish we had security
footage to [ __ ] analyze
if someone done a cheeky [ __ ] that they
bring it and drop it in like
did they do it in the kayak and then
just [ __ ] scooch it in like what
happened
i should stay i i wake up in cold sweat
wondering how did that [ __ ] go wait were
there like
adults in the kayak no it was just like
15 14
13 year olds what 15 14 year old is like
i'm a [ __ ] in this pool kids are [ __ ]
weird man kids kids are weird well you
think like after like the age of 12 you
think like
there is there is like a mental like
stop in my brain to be like
no pooping in the pool is bad some kids
are so dirty though i don't give a [ __ ]
gross yeah i mean i mean like even just
pissing in the pool right i've
i've done it everyone's done it it's
something we're
gonna pretend like i don't piss in the
pool it's something it's it's something
that we don't like
like to admit but of course everyone's
done it everyone does it right
right right sounds like smelling your
own fart
sometimes you know you just get in the
pool and you realize [ __ ] i need a piss
yeah i just got in yeah i don't want to
get out i'm gonna get an ass i'm gonna
everyone else is doing it we're all just
drinking each other's piss anyway this
pool is massive
oh no it's got it's got chlorine in it
for a reason wave it around a bit
whatever it is what what that that's a
[ __ ]
pool it's a public pool
michael phelps says he pisses in the
pool if michael phelps can piss in the
pool
i can piss him yeah it propels him right
it's like an extra check
the gold standard of swimmers if he can
piss in the pool as far as i'm concerned
i can piss them it's like a jet
propelled right it's just like through
here you know
i'm not [ __ ] in the pool you know
big difference between pissing and
shooting one of them evacuates the pool
the other one
is the thing everything everyone else is
doing it's not a problem i will not have
to justify pissing an actor
i don't just get in every pool and i'm
like
i'm about to pee all i'm saying is that
you know if you've got a wetsuit on or
something it's like
i'm you know what i'm going to make
myself warm